All right. Uh, thanks everyone for uh,
the technical difficulties. I really
appreciate the AV staff here. Um, I'll
just get started and we'll just we'll
just work with what we got. Um, hey
everyone. Uh, thanks for coming to my
talk. I'm Matt Masel. I'm CTO and
co-founder of Cinderea. Uh, we're
building trustworthy uh, agent partners
and I' I've spent the last 15 years at
the intersection of machine learning,
security, and software engineering.
Today I'm going to be showing you how we
can uh hook uh coding agents and
adjudicate their actions using the Cedar
policy language. Um and if you're in
this uh track today, there's a lot of
good background material. This is a
lightning talk, so we're going to we're
going to move really fast. We're
actually going to unroll the coding
agent loop and uh and build a policy
harness all within the next 10 minutes.
Um so coding agent scaffolds plan,
generate, execute code, and run tools
and loops. uh we can map this action
space into a trajectory event model that
consists of uh five four event types
actions observations control and state.
Um let's say an agent's maybe already
working on some coding task. It's had a
plan. It's going and generating code
triggering actions. So starting at the
bottom left uh we have uh the agent
initiating uh initiating actions such as
writing or modifying files running shell
commands uh executing code um and these
actions are all um mutating the
environment that that agent's operating
in. Um the environment then emits an
observation uh back to the agent
providing feedback to the next model
inference call.
Uh meanwhile we also have control events
right that handle user prompts,
permission requests, uh sub agent, agent
orchestration. Um and then we have state
events that handle uh mechanics like
memory compaction, pruning, um
environment snapshots, uh and so forth.
So uh with this event model, we can
actually take our now canonical lethal
trifecta threat model and map it to
these trajectory events. And we can see
that this just becomes uh untrusted
input, right? coming from things like
skills which might be fetched you know
over web fetch coming from a marketplace
and returned as an observation right as
as a as as untrusted data which might
have injections. We might already have
sensitive data like source code or
internal docs in the agent context or
retrieve from memory. Um and then
through state changes right uh with to
make this complete lethal trifecta we
would have like shell commands or code
execution right that would uh would lead
to xfill of that data. Um but this is
just one narrow threat model um data
Xfell. And with this trajectory model we
can do we can do more complex um even
multi multi-step attacks right that are
uh going to have observations and
actions over multiple turns of the loop
that might involve uh control events and
state events. Um and we can also map
other threat and risk models like OAS
top 10 for aentic applications to this.
Um, and this is really just looking uh
helping us really map where we want to
have control over the exact boundaries
around these events and where they're
produced. And this is where uh reference
monitors uh come in. So we want a
reference monitor sitting um outside the
agent in the model, right? To mediate
every event. Uh ideally this monitor is
always invoked. It's tamperproof and
verifiable. So it acts as our our hard
security boundary between the agent
control observation action and state
events and where they're you know
produced by the agent and by the system
in the environment. Um but a reference
monitor by itself is it's only as good
as the policy enforcement uh points that
it supports right where we can exert our
control and where we can hook in. And
that's again that's where uh where agent
coding hooks come into play. So hooks
allow us to intercept these trajectory
events, processes them, decide whether
to allow, modify or stop the agents
loop. So we're changing the agents
behavior. Um, and this is invoked at
different life cycle uh stages of of the
agent loop. And each coding agent uh
implementation has its own details. Uh
Gemini CLI, for example, has uh before
and after model hooks uh which let you
stream individual tokens and and do uh
processing on them. uh cloud code
doesn't um actually have any model hooks
at all other than the final agent
response uh that's returned as a
notification event type. And then cursor
has pretty granular uh hook types for
MCP um shell commands as well as more
generic tool calls. Um so with these
hook life cycle events again at each of
these these each of these key event
types, we now have a policy um
enforcement point. Um now we need a way
to express policies around this model.
So uh we're we're choosing Cedar uh in
this implementation um to authorize
these trajectory events and really the
actions of the agent and we're invoking
that processing and authorizing uh
whenever each hook events triggered. So
Cedar is a policy language that's
expressive, fast and analyzable uh
thanks to its formal properties and uh
use of um the lean symbolic compiler. Um
unlike other policy languages like Rego,
uh Cedar policies can be analyzed
through through this uh these hormone
methods to to check for contradictory
vacuous or other shadowed policy
subsets. Um and Cedar also has a nice uh
support for permission models like
attribute-based access control uh which
maps nicely nicely to this domain. So
you can see an example of this by
looking at this uh shell command action
and context type in the middle um where
we can see different schemas uh for the
entities uh entities like agent and user
and trajectory. And this is where we can
add attributes uh with signature tags um
or data sensitivity classifications and
and other other attributes that might
come from safety models or other other
other guardrails that we're we're using
right to compute values uh and compute
attributes for these uh these policies.
Um and policies don't just need to be
security oriented. Uh they can also be
uh for agent behavior. Um so this is uh
it turns out in fact that claude code
lets you write files while in plan mode.
Um, so we can have policies that look
for this type of behavior. Uh, and when
permission mode is set to plan, which
this is coming that's specific to cloud
code actions, uh, we can we can check to
see if it's planned, we can forbid the
right unless that it's it's the actual
plan file that it's writing to. Um, so
at Cinderea, we we covered this actually
in detail in some research that we
released uh, uh, yesterday. Um, finally,
uh, we can also source policy content
from our agent context itself. So uh
like claude MD or cursor rules files and
we can take um some of the uh security
permissions intent right in these files
and formalize them as cedar policies. Um
and in this example we're we're form
we're forbidding the agent from
performing shell executions based off of
pattern matching on certain commands
destructive commands or uh retrieving of
certain environment uh files. Um so at
this point we have our policies. The
next step is setting up policy decision
points uh to have our hook events
trigger. So let's build up now uh part
by part a hookbased harness. So we have
our local adapters which are uh commands
that are run uh by the coding agents.
They intercept these hook events uh over
standard in uh they transform them into
a trajectory event model and then send
them to a local harness service. Uh
inside the harness service we have our
policy a cedar policy engine that
extracts the entities process them
against um you know any guardrail. So
it's kind of meant to be bring your own
guardrail but currently we have yara
signatures uh information flow control
models and a safety model. Um and then
uh from these results we also update the
entity and trajectory stores uh for
stful bookkeeping about information
about the entities that we're we're
observing.
Uh writing cedar policies can be tedious
uh but again thanks to its formal
properties we can generate them with
models and then verify and analyze them
uh with built-in language tools. So we
can have a policy agent uh that helps us
author and validate uh when given policy
features uh in context over MCP tools.
Um so finally now we have this complete
uh harness uh that's hook based. Um so
let's let's kind of go through a few
examples of this.
So
uh first we'll look at um uh some policy
generation. So we have a skill that's
shipped with this that just has the
procedural knowledge about Cedar and
some instructions on how to call these
different tools that are exposed. So
first we have the agent actually fetch
the available uh context and and values
right that are available for these
entities. Um and maybe we're just going
to start writing a policy and we'll tell
it to go write some policies for shell
injection. Um we can see some examples
that are returned around the entity
types that are available from the
schema. We can see different uh context
types and um if if we keep going up here
too we can also see different entities
actually for the these are label values
for information flow control. So the
sensitivity labels that we'll be looking
at as well as the categories from our
policy model that we expose. Um in this
case it's policies around secure code
generation and then uh the various Yara
signature categories that we have in in
our Yara uh uh rule set. Um so let's
look at some more examples of this. So
here's a uh a blocking of a destructive
uh command a destructive action. So
maybe we have some seed policies that
you know look for SQL uh mutations that
don't have any constraints. So in this
case like a delete from users without a
wear clause. Um so we can tell cloud to
go run this. We can stop this and bring
back uh bring back the the policy
violation and context for the agent then
to use to either steer um or for for a
review by the user. Um we can also do
again more sophisticated multi-turn
things here with the stful bookkeeping.
Um we have we can do information flow
control where maybe in this in this case
we're using Gemini CLI. Maybe Gemini uh
we have like a a name, a date of birth
and and an address, right? some PII um
we can uh track that type of highly
confidential PII and taint the
trajectory so that way on on subsequent
turns uh of the agent when maybe it's
going to go do a web fetch or run some
network command and we know that that
trajectory has sensitive information in
the context um we can dynamically
restrict access to those tool calls um
so we'll see here very shortly this web
fetch uh to Google uh here fail and
we'll we'll turn back uh return back a
context text again uh in a similar way.
Um and again these are just the the
policy examples here on the side where
the actions web fetch and we see the the
trajectory resource label. Um finally uh
we'll look at this last demo uh with
cursor. Um so this is demonstrating an
instance of lethal trifecta where let's
say we have a a skill from a public
marketplace uh that helps us generate uh
code metrics to to tell us how good of
vibe uh coders we are. Um unbeknownst to
us there's this metrics.python Python
script in here that does some
environment variable harvesting and then
uh does some uh does some requests to
send that data out. So we can actually
analyze that uh command uh event the
shell command event and process the uh
the metrics.pay file and run it against
all of our guardrails our our signatures
and again uh have that context uh
available to us in our policy to to
block it. Um so wrapping this up uh
because again this is a a rapid tour. Uh
first uh I'm leaving you uh today with
an open- source uh Cedar policy engine
that's integrated with these various
coding agent hooks. Um this is a
deterministic policy engine that's
outside the model. So you know we we
don't have to simply rely on safeguards
or instructions and prompts. Uh this
complements uh other defense and depth
systems like sandboxes or permission
systems. uh right permission systems can
induce consent fatigue and have missing
context. Uh sandbox systems might be
overly restrictive. Um and we can get uh
the trajectory context here in our
policy engine. Um some challenges uh
there is a uh of course uh sort of this
goldilocks policy zone where we we still
have to optimize our policies you know
depending on the context of the agent.
So we don't want overly restrictive
policies that uh the the utility
and then we also don't want brittle
pattern matching on certain signature
certain uh destructive commands as an
example that could invite policy
hacking. Um so this is an area where we
have some ongoing research with
optimization and uh guardrail latency uh
benchmarking. Um so we also have uh
policy scalability right the policy
agent can help us uh with the formal
tools provided over MCP with the ability
to do agent assisted policy generation.
Um and then finally just touching on you
know more uh the the next uh kind of
future of like maybe multi-turn stateful
policies. You know steer is inherently
stateless but because of the um entity
and trajectory store we can do
bookkeeping about the entities that we
observe in the trajectory over time and
allow us to expose those attributes as
as dynamic attributes. But there's other
logic systems uh like temporal linear
logic and others that have more support
for those types of operations um over
over time over trajectories. Um, so with
that, uh, thanks for your time. Here's
the QR code to the, uh, the GitHub repo
with this work. Uh, happy to take
questions and, uh, and talk afterward as
well, too.
>> Anyone have questions?
>> Uh, regarding the IFC model, are you
tagging the datas or the labels of the
data using AI?
>> Yeah. So this is a uh a safety model.
This is the GPT safeguards 20 billion
model that has like a a policy like
basically policies that you provided as
examples for your your sensitivity
labels. Um so that's how that
classification is done. It could be from
another DLP system from another data
classification system uh for that for
that label for that information.
>> Okay. And this is labeling on the entire
data instead of like some segment of
>> so this is labeling on the events
themselves with whatever data is
retrieved or what whatever event is
present in in the events themselves.
>> Uh a great talk. Thank you very much. So
quick questions. um you you write these
policies uh in some language that's fine
but uh who decides what should the
policy be for a given agent the authors
of the agents decide it and uh in terms
of the implementation not the model as
much as the implementation of the agents
do you put them in the pre-post hooks of
the um of the tool calls and agent LLM
calls and that sort of stuff if you can
get some under the hood det Yeah. So I
kind of alluded to it a little bit, but
this is where I think context from your
cloud MD or your cursor rules files like
there we're already putting a lot of
sort of permission and security intent
in there, you know. So you might be on
an engineering team where there's
certain files or certain operations on
infrastructure and again we're again
we're making this trade-off of giving
the agent more access and given more
utility to do useful things for us and
then trying to dynamically determine
when to revoke that access, right? It's
the whole lease privileges thing. But
yeah like that the idea there would be
it would be per team that could be uh in
your uh markdown files or it could come
from your policy documents you know for
your engineering best practices uh uh
operating practices uh in in your
environment.
>> I'm sorry I can hear hear the code
question
Identity. Oh yeah so identity is not
covered in here but um any IDP could be
added in here like this is like Cedar
sort of bread and butter. Um so that
also could be used as well too. We focus
on the attribute based access control uh
in this uh in this work.
>> Hey Matt, great talk. Um I'm curious how
does Cedar policy engine work with first
party agents? uh whether it's based on
lang chain co-pilot studio stuff like
that.
>> Yeah. So uh we also open source like a
cedar policy engine for like any uh
right now supported Python libraries
like lang chain strands ADK um and
others but yeah so it could also be
embedded within those first party agents
as well too.
>> Great.
Anybody else?
>> Matt had a lot of time. He finished up
early.
Hey Matt, thanks for the talk. Um, you
mentioned kind of towards the end how
this is complimementaryary with like a
permission system. Could you just talk
about that a little more?
>> Yeah, so I think a good example would be
like in in cloud code permissions,
right? You might uh have bash and you
might again similar to maybe with some
of those Cedar policies where you're
wild carding on certain commands. Great.
You can still do that, but with Cedar
you can have more context. You can have
more you can allow permissions but only
when the trajectory is not tainted with
uh some information flow control. label.
So that would be one example.
>> Thanks.
>> Anybody else? Oh, there we go. Down
front.
>> You mentioned um using this bookkeeping
across multi-turn conversations. Have
you experimented with multi- aent
architectures where you have like
convergence and divergence of
trajectories? So I think this is where
it gets uh kind of this is single agent
like focus on single agents right now
but the uh the sort of control event
types is that place where you can see
when and another agent spawned like a
sub agents created or maybe there's more
like agent to agent communications. Um
so as far as like thinking of this as a
another like agent to agent sort of
boundary policies that maybe again more
like contextual integrity like sort of
use cases of an agent knows one secret
you can't let other agents in the
environment know that secret. This could
be another another mechanism but uh that
work is is not to be done yet in this
work.